Yeah, they need to stay in the bubble. I think baseball's probably,
I would give it a 0% chance of finishing the season,
but I think the NBA will be okay because they're staying,
they're going to stay in the bubble. Yeah.
And this is the time the excitement's a little down because there's no fans or
whatever. This is the time where you just,
you got to look the other way with steroids.
Let these boys juice up and roid, rage all over each other.
I don't want to see a home run. I want them to see them hit Pluto. Yeah.
It's a different, yeah. So by the way, why, why do they,
why are people against steroids at all? Like, here's what happens when you're,
when you have a policy against steroids,
is that all these little kids grow up thinking, Oh,
I'm going to be a baseball star. I'm going to be an Olympic star.
I'm going to be a weightlifting star, a bicyclist.
And then they finally reached like the top 100 in the world and somebody tells
them, Hey, we forgot to tell you.
You need to start taking this if you want to wait. Yeah. Well we have a,
we got it. We got a steroid expert on our podcast, Chris,
what's it like to do cycles.
I've done a few cycles of Winstrol and I've never felt better. I'm back on it.
And um, I, I agree with you, James. And I've been saying this, I think,
especially baseball. It's so boring.
It's unbelievable how boring it is. And now there's no fans.
Even my dad was watched baseball his whole life. He's like,
I can't sit through a nine inning game anymore. Have ever had that least,
if you want to have a steroid league and a regular league.
And in the steroid league, one player out one batter,
a game gets a metal bat. They put boards up around the stadium.
They put the pitcher in like riot gear. And you know,
you have a chance to get an 800 foot home run. And it's a pack of the pitcher.
You know, maybe the pitcher dies. Maybe he does it. And you know, seriously.
Cause it's like, well, how long can we continue with this? Yeah. I mean,
we've got to adapt to the times. No more traditional sports.
Like Chris is saying new sport, you got a federal courthouse. You got 10 Antifa,
you got 10 proud boys fighting.
Ultimate protests are fighting a new American gladiators.
Who's going to win the communists or the libertarians have added baby,
put them in a dome and let them go. I agree with that.
How many people like Chris when you started taking steroids?
I don't even know if it's a joke or not. When you started taking steroids,
did someone say like, Hey man, if you want to be great at basketball, take this.
What happened? Was his jump got a little bigger,
but then occasionally he would punch a few meter maids.
It's one is what happens, you know, relatively punch a Chinese on the street.
It happens. It's what happens. It's called roid rage. I was 19 years old.
I was 19 years old. I did a cycle, a Winnie.
We used to call it Winstrol and yeah. I mean, why did you take it though?
Like why, why did you, that would be a good thing. And by the way,
I'm not arguing whether it's a good thing or not, but why did you take it?
Cause I, I don't know, dude,
he was playing basketball and he needed to try to compete with the blacks when
he, I ask him what he is. I mean, it.
It's a simple answer for a question like that. And he's a white kid.
He was playing basketball. There's a lot of of blacks and play basketball.
You want to jump higher? You got to take a little, it is a lot of,
I mean, do my vertical leap went up like four inches.
I was putting up like two 50, like 20 times at once,
but it didn't help my jump shot. It didn't help. Like, yeah, it gave advantages.
But like that's my argument, baseball. It's like,
you still have to play the sport. Like all these events,
all these talks about it gives you an unfair advantage.
It's like kind of in baseball, kind of it does.
You still have to be so good at baseball.
We really hope you enjoyed that episode. Whatever it was about.
This is just a stock thing that we're taping on temporary episode.
So go make sure you rate, review us, subscribe,
turn on your notifications,
get jiggy with it and go to patron.com/bay Ridge boards where things get really
wild.